so it's not been a very good a time for
Apple products in the etheric household
jenna got her MacBook stolen oh oh my
gosh
shattered cut your head I know I know I
was holding Maddy and I was trying to
get up on the elevator and as I like put
the key fob to the door
Maddy pulled really really hard my phone
was in my hand and it just felt just
like this
face down genj you won't come here and
talk about something real quick
poor Gemma got her computer still it and
we're not really sure how it happened
you made a video dad exhale but like
we're not sure if it was left in the
hotel but there's no possible way she
would left that room like without you
and me baby I know that's like I said
that's like if I love Maddy no tell room
like I wouldn't do that I know no news I
even did a last sweep of it and now I
have a shattered phone cookie Maddy is
though I mean I guess the Apple store is
still open so you got third street who
wants to go wow that's a big shatter it
something like so no it's like a I can't
use my phone well I just wanted to say
hi and bye and what's that what's that
you you want it really quick yeah real
quick you guys my puzzle came in the
mail what are you looking at Matt I'm
just looking at what it looks like I got
a new lens and Matt's over there like
creeped it like don't move don't let my
camera around this one has to it
[Music]
well turn around I like it a lot oh my
god it says Beauty boy I thought it said
built by and I was like wait that says
beauty boy some white stuff on the hard
buttons wait you get an H out scuf
controller this is the controller guys
looks good doesn't that look great
those look nice back what's wrong oh
there's no paddle Needham I win with
fewer buttons woohoo this day it seems
so long I woke up at like 5:00 oh yeah
I know the apples oh my god la there's a
hole in it well can you see it on the
screen careful don't cut yourself it's
super sharp there's a hole in my phone a
screw I guarantee I hit the hole on this
door first fry first truck no absolutely
awful Siri make me a Genius Bar
appointment now okay I set up your
appointment for today
show me nothing I didn't swear get em
some corn sir there's another another's
an Apple support app hmm
there's an Apple support app okay now
let that me either that's new because I
couldn't make an appointment off of the
Apple Store where I usually do it this
is crazy look it's got oh my god it has
a hole holy crap all the times you got
support no it has all of the items that
I currently have have possible access to
oh my gosh there's nothing I'm just sad
little Wow well that's it I just want to
show you with you guys the sad news of
what happened and least my dogs cute I
didn't get my computer stolen like Jenna
I'll keep you guys posted but as of now
I can't get a reservation for like three
days until Monday that's crazy okay mom
oh my gosh it smells so lovely
it says interpretation because this
definitely doesn't smell like a new Mac
I don't think at all but if it is an
interpretation then it smells very very
lovely so for those of you that have
never smelled a new